hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast i'm your host sean carroll
and increasingly one of the things that
people are talking about in the
political and economic realms in the
world today
is the problem of equality or the
problem of inequality i should put it
that way
we live in a world where inequality is
growing in poor countries and in wealthy
countries we have a bigger and bigger
gap
between the ultra-rich and the very poor
and
some people will say you know what
that's just how it should be
you know jeff bezos is just that much
more talented than you are
he deserves all of his money other
people will say
well you know he deserves to earn as
much money as he can but we have the
right to tax
him there should be a little bit of
redistribution because
the flow of wealth does not exactly
match on to
merit in some sense so we should be able
to use the wealth of the very uh rich
people to help out those who are less
well-off
maybe it would be good in other words to
decrease the amount of inequality in a
financial sense
but all that's just about the equality
of resources right
the equality of stuff of of wealth
almost nobody thinks that you should
have
exactly the same amount of wealth in
every person there might have been some
sort of utopian thinkers or small-scale
communes but
it's not a major position in modern
political thought to say
every person in the united states should
have the same wealth
but what about something like equality
of opportunity
the idea being we come into this world
with certain capacities and you know
some of us are just gonna be better
at other things than others but we
should all have equal opportunity
to let our powers and capacities
flourish and be rewarded for them right
that sounds like an attractive kind of
goal
maybe even that's not the right goal and
my guest today is elizabeth anderson who
is probably
the leading person in the world thinking
about
equality from a philosophical point of
view i'm very proud to have her on the
podcast it's not like
i've discovered her anything she is a
leading person she was uh
the subject of a new yorker magazine
profile but she's not nearly as well
known
as she could be so i'm hoping that this
is a discourse
a conversation that a lot of people
haven't yet been exposed to
and uh elizabeth became famous in the
philosophy
politics of equality discourse with an
article in 1999 called what is the point
of equality
where she actually goes against the idea
of equality of opportunity
being the thing that we should aim for
not from a sort of conservative point of
view that says we shouldn't even aim for
equality
but that we should aim for a different
kind of equality and i i have to read
the opening of this article that she
wrote because it's one of the best
openings of a philosophy article i've
ever read she says
if much recent academic work defending
equality had been secretly penned by
conservatives
could the results be any more
embarrassing for egalitarians
her point being that the kind of
equality that the purportedly
progressive
side of the debate is championing is
actually a little bit not very
progressive at all it can really
decrease the dignity and value of human
existence
and so she is arguing not for equality
of opportunity
but for equality of treatment for a sort
of democratic equality where
we focus on the social roles that people
have
and the way that they relate to each
other trying to make each other flourish
in this world
in an equal way rather than just trying
to hand out money so that everyone has
the same amount i'm probably butchering
that a little bit she'll say it a lot
better
than we do in this conversation so one
of the great things about elizabeth is
that she's a philosopher but she's
heavily influenced
by empirical work by history by
economics by sociology
so we'll talk about her views on
equality but then also back up to talk
about
the work ethic right the protestant work
ethic the free market system who
invented the free market system
how is the meaning of how we think about
the free market
changed over time and what does it mean
today compared to what it meant for
adam smith and thomas paine and so forth
i think this is an eye-opening
conversation because we need to be
having this conversation there's a whole
bunch of people
on both sides of the political spectrum
who are really frustrated
by the differences between the haves and
have-nots in society today
it would be a good idea to ameliorate
them somehow
but if we can't even agree on what that
means at the philosophical level it
becomes impossible to imagine
what our political or activist goals
should be so
we have to have this conversation this
is the right time to have it
let's go
elizabeth anderson welcome to the
mindscape podcast it's great to be here
so uh i wanted you you're doing so many
different things
and uh i think it's fascinating stuff i
want to get into
sort of the nitty-gritty because you
engage a lot with the real world
uh by philosopher standards right uh but
maybe we can start with
settings the stage a little bit with
some uh
background ideas about how you go about
approaching these things um
one idea i wanted to ask you about was
you mentioned
i only saw a brief mention of it but
maybe you talk about it uh at greater
length elsewhere
the idea of ideology in the in the intro
to your book on private government
and actually i've heard the word
ideology and used it myself for many
decades of my life but i think you
changed
my appreciation of it because you know
as a physicist as a scientist i think a
lot about the fact that people have
models of the world
right and you know they they have ideas
about what's going to happen next and
they
update uh if things go wrong and stuff
like that
and in some sense am i crazy to think
that you're you're saying that we should
think of ideology as just the social
version of that
i mean an ideology is absolutely yeah
that's exactly right and
the thing is is that it's used for
practical purposes
we have a picture of our social world
which we use to navigate our way through
right and so the ideology in this sense
does not have to be pernicious
yes that's right so there's sort of it's
not a pejorative use of the term
right right but it can become pernicious
if our picture of our social world
is either missing some major elements
or maybe distorted in various ways that
leads us
perhaps to you know behave badly or
treat other people unjustly
right exactly and i think let's just
emphasize this non-pejorative
uh you sense of the word because we'll
probably be using it later on
um that everyone has an ideology it's
not a bad thing to be ideological in
this sense right it's it's sort of how
you approach the world in terms of
what you what you pay attention to what
you expect to see
and what it all means to you is that
something close that's quite right
although i wouldn't necessarily say that
everyone has
one ideology often what happens is
in different social contexts we we take
on
different ideologies okay right to
navigate that part of the social world
that we're engaging at the moment so i
actually don't think that
most people have very coherent
worldviews
some people right philosophers are paid
to have a coherent worldview but
i wouldn't even guarantee that i have
such a coherent worldview in my
everyday life no i've met some
philosophers and you know they're no
better than scientists
in this regard um yeah good but uh
but okay so the ideology in in that
sense i mean it is
it is a necessary thing because there's
an infinite amount of things we could
pay attention to or care about and we
sort of filter
some things out but let's also admit
there can be a negative
side to it yes absolutely yes because we
could be missing out on major parts of
our social world
or just profoundly misunderstanding
the nature of our social world and that
can lead to major problems
in how we navigate our way through it
and how we treat other people
i wish i had this this word or concept
available when i was talking to paul
bloom
psychologist at yale you know he's
written this wonderful book on
being against empathy he thinks that
empathy is a bad idea because we tend to
empathize with people like ourselves
and i was trying to say that well but
the response to that should be to
empathize with people
not like ourselves because otherwise we
get trapped in this ideology where
we uh think about the world in terms of
what's happening to people like
us and and it would be nicer if we could
make more of an effort
to think about what's happening to
people very much unlike ourselves
you know i think what you just said is
really beautiful
and i've written about this um a paper i
wrote
uh last year called the epistemology of
justice
ah and what i argue there is that
the core way that one of the main ways
we have to cut through
pernicious unjust ideology is
because our emotions like empathy
have natural objects
and and you know empathy just we can
react
just to the fact that somebody's
suffering and in fact
if we look at the empathetic imagination
we see in children
i mean they have empathy towards stuffed
animals real animals and stuffed animals
right there's no boundaries because the
natural object of empathy
is any being who is able to
have suffering or joy or even
you can even project that on to an
inanimate object like a stuffed animal
right but our hearts go out right or in
movies you know it's fiction but your
heart goes out to
the characters if they are really
compelling yeah
right and and it's it's and we can
that can break those emotional reactions
can break through
it's interesting ideology i feel a
little bit bad for paul bloom because
you know
uh he did a great podcast interview with
me and ever since then i've been
having other people in the podcast where
i recall our conversation and go don't
you think i was right
i should have him back on to you know
defend himself from these but
but good there's ideologies good and bad
aspects um one of the other things i
wanted to get on the stage before we dig
into the
nitty-gritties of work and equality and
things like that is
this whole idea of doing historically
economically
informed philosophy right i mean you're
not just working from your armchair has
that
how conscious is that choice how weird
is it within the profession
you know it's absolutely conscious and
let me tell you where i got it from
i was an undergraduate at swarthmore
college studying philosophy
and i was an economics minor but
okay the most transformative course i
ever took
in my entire life was a course
on the history and philosophy of science
and so we studied the history of like
basically the history of astronomy and
physics
from the ancient greeks to like new and
it was an
absolutely fascinating course and then
we could see how the arguments developed
right
and and the context of philosophical
ideas and metaphysics and epistemology
and it made me think why don't we
ethics that way and political philosophy
that is that the philosophy of science
is undertaken with engagement to
metaphysical and epistemological
problems that arise
in those other disciplines and then
right there are all these puzzles about
how could you know
yeah right or you know do atoms really
exist
or something like this right but they're
cut these are
questions that are suggested by or
arising from
domains of inquiry and practice outside
of philosophy
right and it was really that was the
thing that really excited me because we
could do this
in moral and political philosophy too
where you take your problems
from practice from the problems that
people actually encounter in their lives
and then start theorizing from that
rather than thinking no i'll just i'm
just going to think in my head
right and figure out like first
principles of morality and politics
just just by sticking to ideas in my
head and i think that's just wrong
just as it was wrong it meant you know
if you look in the history of modern
philosophy
metaphysics and epistemology were
fundamentally
deep questions of how to make sense of
the scientific revolution in this new
discoveries that didn't make sense in
the old aristo well it's interesting
because i do think that philosophy
has a much stronger engagement with its
own history with the history of
philosophy
then let's say science does like
physicists don't care about the history
of physics but philosophers of physics
do care about it so
you're saying that philosophers of
ethics or
society should care about not just the
history of the philosophy of ethics
but the history of society and economics
and
that sounds great but it also sounds
like a lot more work it is a lot more
work
but it's a total blast yeah okay
um it does mean that you have to be a
very
very heavy consumer of history and
social science
i think i remember a quote from you
about you know you wanted to go
back in your some work that you were
doing to the 1700s but then
you had to go back to the reformation
but then that was based on the bible and
you have to read the new testament and
there's no
there is no beginning unless you go back
to the big bang ultimately
[Laughter]
yeah yeah so i am working on a history
of egalitarianism and
and i i decided i actually have to go
back to our hunter-gatherer ancestors
yep fair enough at least as you don't
worry about these single-celled
organisms so
you're drawing the line somewhere i
think that's pretty good yeah and this
actually
that that's good because uh you
mentioned something which was the final
point i wanted to get
uh on the table which is this role of
ideal theory the idea that you know
whether as philosophers or anybody else
one way of thinking about how to make
society better is to say well what would
the perfect
society be and then how close are we are
to that and can we move in that
direction
and i think that you push back a little
bit on that common philosophical
move yeah because how are we supposed to
know what the ideal's going to be
we don't even know what the normative
categories are going to be like a
century from now maybe we'll think that
that other things are critically imp so
is it
go ahead you know if you look at
say the emergence of environmental
philosophy is a thing
that's relatively new uh but we do have
to
think about what are our ecosystems
going to look like and how should we
live with nature
it's going to have to be important
question for how we organize
ourselves so that's interesting because
i would have thought
that one of the biggest objections to
being ideal theory focused is that
it's a way to paper over some of the
real world structural
inequities or barriers in society uh but
you're you you're you're just
well that's also true that's also true
right right i mean that is that
ideal theory can often not
fail to address the problems before us
and the usefulness of non-ideal theory
of starting with the problems that we're
facing
is that then we develop categories of
concepts and tools
that are appropriate for inquiry in our
very non-ideal world
right but but you but you brought up a
different reason
uh to object to it which is more like a
fallablism kind of claim
that you know maybe the ideal theory is
so far away
that we should be more locally centered
because we might discover whole new
things we need to worry about as we as
we approach the ideal theory
or maybe moral inquiry and political
inquiry just goes on forever
and never stabilizes or converges on
something
because we get keep on coming up with
new ideas
i've been actually a very recent convert
to exactly that
idea i mean uh the idea that
there is no perfect morality or
political system out there to be found
like there is a theory of everything in
physics it's more a reaction to our
present circumstances and trying to make
things
better we should think about the moment
in our current journey rather than this
ultimate imaginary destination
that's quite right and i want to add
that because i'm not doing
ideal theory it doesn't follow that i
don't believe in ideals
i think ideals are really important yeah
but we should treat them
as error prone uh
uh but the way we find out whether our
ideals
are wrong is by living in accordance
with them
and seeing whether we like the results
very
it's that constant learning
that we have in learning to live through
our ideals
that we are constantly changing them and
coming up with new ideas all the time
we're all writing more and more in this
electronic age and how you write
matters more and more we all want to be
able to write better right i want to be
able to write better
well grammarly premium is here to help
us along
the way that i personally use grammarly
premium is just to improve the strength
of my writing you know we all have ruts
we fall into we have favorite words
favorite constructions
and grammarly doesn't just check your
spelling or check your grammar
it actually gives you suggestions for
different vocabulary words
ways to have your writing be more
exciting be more memorable
get the point across that you actually
want to get across
rather than having it be lost in your
verbiage and you can use grammarly
premium to improve your writing on all
your favorite sites and apps from gmail
to twitter blogging whatever you do so
do more than just spell checks say what
you really mean with grammarly premium
get 20
off grammarly premium by signing up at
grammarly.com
mindscape that's 20 off at g r a
m a r l y dot com slash mindscape
good good and that's a perfect segue
into the sort of nitty-gritty about what
you've been talking about
what you've been working on uh for a
number of years now by the way i wonder
if we overlapped on the main line i was
an undergraduate at villanova uh you
just said you were an undergraduate
at swarthmores we were probably nearby
each other oh yeah yeah so when did you
graduate
i graduated 88 from villanova oh no no
i'm older than you
i graduated in 81 from swarthmore
college
all right okay well all right still
still nearby i visited swarthmore while
i was there
um let's think about equality
you talked a lot about equality and i
think that uh you're at a slightly
higher level
than uh many of us here because um
i think as soon as the word equality
comes up the immediate dichotomy that
comes to many people's minds is sort of
equality of opportunity versus equality
of outcome right like do you want a
society where everyone has the same
amount of stuff
or do you want a society where the
everyone has the same opportunities to
get stuff and you don't want either one
of those but maybe you could say a
little bit about
whether those are you know two sensible
prevailing notions that we should be
thinking in the back of our minds
yeah i'm not keen on either
[Laughter]
both of them have their flaws it's not
that distributive justice is not
important i do think it is very
important but i want to embed it
in a broader understanding of what what
egalitarianism is about
and in my view it's about how we relate
to each other
it's about human relationships so just a
sort of a quick note
against like a purely distributive
understanding
of equality separate but equal suppose
it had
literally been the case that in the jim
crow era
blacks really got exactly the same
material
goods that whites did nevertheless the
very
fact of segregation inherently
an insult and a form of stigmatization
of black people right because what it
was doing was white people
saying blacks are untouchables they're
not
fit for social engagement with white
people that's what jim crow is saying
and so that's why i think you can't just
look at distribution you have to look at
what the meanings of various practices
are
and these relationships of
stigmatization and exclusion and
marginalization
right these are the way people relate to
each other and that's why i find that
fundamental
and it's not just a distinction between
economic goods and social goods it goes
a little bit deeper than that is that
fair to say
well i would say that concerns about
distributive justice are going to
follow from the demands of relating to
each other as equal
and in fact they could be quite
stringent demands although
they wouldn't entail exact material
and the reason for that is that if you
try to achieve exact material equality
at all times you're going to have to
have basically a totalitarian system
right but but still
you can put parameters on how big the
distance is between the top and the
bottom and those could be
pretty stringent um you don't want
the inequalities to be so extreme that
you have desperate people who are
begging
mercy from people who have all the
wealth i mean maybe you don't want that
but we have it so maybe somebody
somebody wants it yes an hour plutocracy
today
where mark zuckerberg decides you know
what we're gonna see in our yeah what
information we get
right that is a problem i think well
good but i mean there's it there is i
just wanna
uh sort of be very crude about it to
start because there is this
cartoonish straw man that says oh you
want equality
that means that you want just what you
said would be a totalitarian terrible
thing where
literally everyone has the same amount
of stuff right so
just to get on the table nobody's really
in favor of that right that's not
exactly what any equality theorist has
in mind
not today i mean back in the day if you
look at uh
uh a famous french revolutionary
gracchus babuf
oh okay he tried to overthrow the french
directory
the the ruling clique uh at the
at the time and he actually did advocate
absolutely strict material equality
but his way to getting at it was a
totalitarian communist state
where not only not only did everyone
wear
identical clothing yeah but they were
all
directed by you know these cadres
and assigned to their jobs and
and their thought was controlled
it's a pretty repressive regime and he
understood that if you let people think
for themselves and
you know they're not necessarily going
to be thinking thoughts genial district
material equality
but i think but i think that the
difficulty here
is that he's pursuing material equality
but the only way he sees to achieve this
is by some people dominating other
people and ordering them what to think
and what to
do and i'm thinking well that's an
inequality
right there inequality of relationships
where some people get to issue orders
and other people just have to follow
them
so he didn't actually achieve equality
in this broader
relational sense and it does sound like
that kind of system would be hard to
sell
in the modern era outside of maybe a
tiny commune
here or there but but this other idea of
equality of opportunity
might be considered um popular like
that's an easier sell in our in our
modern era i mean how can you argue
against the idea
that uh everyone should have equal
opportunity how can you argue against
that elizabeth anderson
[Laughter]
well i'm not exactly going to argue
against it so much as
question some of its premises so
how do we even determine when
opportunities are equal and one
formulation which is very popular in
philosophy is take people of equal
underlying potential genetic potentials
and structure opportunities in such a
way
that they have exactly equal chances of
achieving say certain positions
in society or getting access to certain
and i do have
something of a problem with that because
in its background
it assumes that we should all be happy
with a natural aristocracy
sort of promoting itself genetically
through time
[Laughter]
and i i i really don't want to buy into
that picture
so i do think it's very important to
have
open opportunity and by that i mean
many many pathways you know a
choice of occupation but we shouldn't at
all be
confident that we have any idea
whatsoever how to measure
inner merit or inner potential or inner
merit or something like that
um i don't think we can and and
education
and um society should be seen as the
place where people develop
capabilities and we should be focused on
developing
everybody's capabilities and
cultivating multiple pathways success
so i'm just as a non-expert i want to
sort of um
make sure i understand the most
charitable interpretation
of the uh equality of opportunity
position here i mean is the idea that
look some people are going to be born
better basketball players than others
uh that's okay the good basketball
players the taller and more athletic
people
will become better basketball players
but as long as they get the same chance
to try out is that is that basically the
sort of equality of the opportunity
idea well you do want to make sure that
children as they grow up have ample
opportunities to develop their talents
whatever they might be
right but you can't say at birth who's
going to be
like the best basketball player no so
much of that is a product of development
and also of the cultivation of interests
depending on
you know who they're around so that's
why i say it's very important to have
open opportunity
but we can't really define equality of
opportunity
at least not in the conventional sense
as relativized
to some background innate talent or
something like that
and this is also sometimes called luck
egalitarianism
because it so exact why is it called
luck egalitarianism i was never able to
quite suss that out is
we're supposed to correct for being
lucky and unlucky
in right so the idea is that
of luck egalitarianism is that
people should have exactly equal
opportunity
and the all the inequalities that arise
should be things that they
either deserve or are responsible for
right
but differences in luck sheer luck
any inequalities arising from pure
election
okay does being born into a very wealthy
family count as luck
absolutely it does yes from a lucky
egalitarian point of view
and i'm definitely not in favor of a
self-reproducing plutocracy either
so you know i would share with the luck
egalitarian
uh an interest in uh not giving such
advantages people who have been
supposedly well born in this way but i
have a different way of understanding
that
in that any society that creates a self
reproducing insulated elite is going to
be
fundamentally unjust right
but i mean it'll it'll it'll be
oppressive and
right you're gonna have like this elite
that can't even you know
what why do we even have an elite
anyways in the sense of people who are
occupying
positions of high responsibility and
uh power it's because they're supposed
to be serving everybody else
but they can't do that if they're a
self-segregated
self-perpetuating group this does get
into
philosophical issues of another
dimension in some sense i recently
talked to robert sapolsky
uh neuroscientist who traces all the
reasons why
you do what you do and behave the way
you do in the capacities you have and
you know
all of them can be given these
reductionistic explanations in terms of
biology and genetics and heritage so
does it even make you know sort of is it
even
logically coherent to separate out as a
localitarian would want us to do
the luck of our situation that we're
born into but then say
let our natural capacities uh flourish
as they
will if our natural capacities are also
a matter of luck just as much
yeah i mean i think in the end the
distinction that luck egalitarians draw
between outcomes that are due to luck
and outcomes that are due to our choices
for which we're responsible
that is a distinction that's being asked
to bear far too much weight
right okay good so the idea i mean um
it's a free will question in some sense
like at some point
the idea would be that we need to assign
blame or responsibility to choices
people make and the anti-free will
people would say well you can never do
that so
that doesn't help us very much i'm not
i'm not actually advocating any position
here i'm just trying to sort of
understand all the burdens that the luck
egalitarians are placing themselves
under
i i mean i think that's one question
that could be asked but i think there's
even a more fundamental question about
justice and that has to do with the
structure of opportunities
so think about it this way um suppose
you're structuring
an athletic competition and will award
prizes
at the end okay now
should the first place winner get twice
as much
money as the second place winner or a
million times as much
okay and that's a question about how how
you structure the stakes in the
competition
right and that's a question that arises
prior
to any question of who is more
meritorious who ran the fastest or
whatever
you're you've already decided it and and
it's necessary that's a side that the
infrastructure of opportunities is
determined
prior to and independently of any
particular individual's performance
you see what i mean so and so the
question arises
how should you structure those
opportunities and the rewards that are
attached to different
and you know and play and that's
completely independent of what people
deserve
it exists prior to that right you know
and that's really where this that's
where i really think
questions of justice and equality
they're at the structural level
not at the level of individual
performance or choice
that's like a secondary consideration of
who gets what in particular
but prior to that you have to know
what's the structure of opportunities
right and your alternative is you call
it democratic equality and it's more
focused on um just like what you just
said the social conditions
uh and the relationships between people
uh the
putting equality on those terms i guess
that's right and
and that's going to affect the structure
of opportunities
so here's just another metaphor you know
you could think about inequality
like a ladder right there are rungs on
the ladder and they're top rungs and
bottom rung
and you can imagine different rungs are
going to have different width depends
depending on how many people are going
to be on that rung
okay you can imagine the whole
distribution of opportunities along this
ladder metaphor
and my point is that how you structure
say the distance between the top rung
and the bottom run
is going to be independent of anybody's
choice or merit
or how wide the rungs are going to be or
whether say
if we look over time within the united
states
uh since the 1970s the structure has
been ripping out the middle rungs of the
ladder
and fattening the top and the bottom but
that makes it much
more difficult for people at the bottom
to
ascend to the top because there's no
middle rungs to hang on to anymore
right that seems pretty problematic
well so but i have this question about
the sort of uh
boots on the ground implementation of
your version of
equality um if i'm just sort of uh
cold-blooded redistribution
redistributionist
i can imagine sending out money to
everybody uh but but you sort of have a
more warm-hearted version of equality
where we give people equal dignity and
i'm not quite sure how to
implement that in practice as much so
dignity is one aspect of
equality but it's not the whole thing
so one way to think about this is just
in terms of
social theory so sociologists think in
terms of three dimension
of equality or inequality so you have
relationships of domination and
subordination
like who gets to order who around and
you know there
has to be some something of that right
in the sense that say within any any
large organization there's going to be a
hierarchy of
yeah where managers are going to be
setting some priorities and then telling
subordinates what to do
right um and then you have hierarchies
of uh honor and stigmatization
that's a second dimension and and then
you have hierarchies of what i call
standing which has to do with how much
your interests count
in the deliberations of third party okay
and especially the state
so you know when people in congress are
deliberating about legislation
whose interests are they really have in
mind and interested they give weight to
okay and egalitarians say is you know we
want equality on all three dimensions
not absolutely strict equity but we'd
like to flatten these hierarchies
and and and make sure that they don't
interact in such a way
that they're all all three of them are
all constantly aligned
and rewarding the exact same people
[Laughter]
right so if you think say of stigma
and honor as one dimension one useful
egalitarian strategy
is to proliferate the dimension of
things that are admired and that's what
you get in a pluralistic society
um right people different people value
different things
and you know there's nobody who's a
winner on all dimensions
you know who's both the most beautiful
and the smartest and the most athletic
and you know right the most pious right
right no you have different communities
that value different things
right and that's good good good that
that makes a lot of sense and it does
resonate with especially this
uh standing dimension which maybe i have
not really uh
known about before but that does
resonate with complaints
on both the left and right sides of the
political spectrum with the current
system where
people just don't feel like they do have
a voice right people just don't feel
like
their needs are being heard in
washington or in brussels or wherever it
is
and it leads to this kind of populist
backlash in various
manifestations in various different
circumstances oh you're totally right
about that i mean populism is
always a reaction to the feeling that
uh one is not being effectively
represented
in the political system but again how i
mean maybe maybe you said this maybe i
missed it
how do we bring this about what what
what laws do we pass
to uh make people more equal along all
these dimensions at once
so you know there's no simple formulas
what instead what one has to do is
examine particular ways
in which problematic inequalities are
manifesting
and drill down and figure out like how
is that
working yeah where and that requires
some causal analysis
so in my book the imperative of
integration
i'm looking at particular at racial
inequality
and specific inequality between blacks
and whites
because that's although i think it does
generalize to a certain degree for other
uh racial groups in the united states
and what i argue is that
racial segregation by which i mean the
self-segregation
of white people to themselves
is really a critical and central feature
of all three dimensions of
uh uh racial hierarchy yeah okay
so you have the hoarding of economic
opportunities
which generates inequality of standing
but then
when when blacks are put into
uh much less advantageous say
educational settings neighborhoods of
concentrated poverty
uh twice as much unemployment
rates as whites for as long as we've
measured this
because there's no job opportunities in
the neighborhoods
where they live uh
then people develop stereotypes about
them
which hook into old rationales for
slavery
you know well they must not be working
so there's a feedback loop yeah
and those those stereotypes are
stigmatizing
right so then you get stigma and
and also blacks have worse opportunities
so they're going to be at the bottom of
the job hierarchy and taking orders from
everybody else
and also politically too right and
so all these things are interacting but
segregation really lies
at the core but if you look at other
kinds of inequality in society
you might find other factors right at
work
as a scientist i know how important it
is to choose the best people to work
with whether it's accepting students
hiring postdocs choosing
new colleagues in the business world
that means it's important to
hire the right people for your company
and indeed.com
is the hiring site that helps you find
quality candidates with indeed instant
match
what indeed does is it searches through
millions of resumes in their database to
help show you the best candidates
for you instantly it's the fastest way
to find the people you're looking for
and there are no long-term contracts you
can pause your account at any time
in other words you're only paying for
what you need and with instant match you
get that list of great candidates with
zero weight
you can start hiring the right people
right away so if you want your quality
short list
fast you need indeed right now our
listeners get a free 75
credit to upgrade your job post at
indeed.com
mindscape this is indeed's best offer
anywhere get a free 75
credit at indeed.com mindscape offer
valid through march 31 terms and
conditions apply
and this brings us to what this other
dimension that you mentioned about the
who gets to order who
around right the domination submission
because you're in this whole book about
private government
where you uh i mean well i'll let you
tell the story but i guess
the story begins with the idea of the
free market
and adam smith and his friends and it it
changes from then
yeah so i'm trying to explain
why it is that stories about the free
market
are so appealing especially in american
discourse and this gets us back to the
question of ideology
and the social map we have of
the american institutional landscape
right
um and so we had see in
political discourse talk about markets
all the time
but not really talk very much talk about
the internal organization of firms or
businesses
where we work and my argument is that
this goes back
to the original free market ideology at
the founding
of the american republic where the ideal
put forth that was eagerly taken up by
americans
was universal self-employment everybody
stakes out their own homestead
or their farm why do i have to answer to
a boss at all
right isn't that kind of the ideal and
even today if you ask americans
what would be ideal many of them say i
don't want to have to answer to a bond
i want to be self-employed and you know
now that people are put at holding out
you know being an uber driver or an
independent contractor
yeah or maybe you know getting involved
in some multi-level marketing scheme
where they're selling vitamins or
something because they're
chasing this dream of self-employment
having a podcast
yeah right exactly yeah
or having your own youtube channel yeah
there you go um
um and people have americans have always
traced chased the dream of
self-employment and in that picture if
everybody were self-employed
and just working their own capital
whatever it might be like the uber
driver owns their own car
you can easily see that that could be a
plausible
picture of how we could also have a
society of so a free society and a
society
will be the same because nobody you you
know one individual
cannot work a huge a huge capital stock
right an uber driver cannot be drive
personally driving
a million cars right only one car at a
time
so everyone's basically equal roughly
seeing and
you know back in the day it was farming
but one person can't farm that much
within another
right so you'd have broad equality and
and we
and we'd all be in competitive markets
trading our
goods and services everybody perfectly
competitive
and so you can see everybody we get you
know in economic theory in a perfectly
competitive market where everybody has
pretty much equal capital
we're all going to be facing each other
as equals nobody with monopoly power
nobody able to order anybody else around
everybody enjoying the dignity of
self-employment
and property ownership and you'd have a
society of equals so that
is sort of the seduction of the market
ideology
and what i argue is historically
americans
in a way we have a kind of massive
cultural lag
and that we continue to talk as if this
market
ideal that really was forged prior to
the civil war
is still a realistic prospect
when in fact we live in a lot in a world
social
very complex division of labor where
we're working in these organizations
called firms or sometimes non-profits
like
you and i right but still big
organizations
right and you know we're not we're not
in a way academics are the most
privileged of all
uh employees like our life is incredible
because we're granted so much autonomy
right we get to think about whatever we
like
but that's of course extraordinarily
rare
even most other professionals don't have
that kind of incredible freedom
right you know a lawyer they have
clients and they just take cases
yeah right it's a very rare and
privileged lawyer who can just turn down
cases
because they don't want to work on those
problems or they don't find them
interesting
i mean if they did have their own
shingle out there then they could but
you're saying that most lawyers work for
law firms and they're told
you know take this case right well they
have well they also just have to
generate
enough revenue so they can stay partners
just be ejected from the partnership
and so then that's a world of bosses
and employees and it's a very different
world
from the free market world because then
you're in a hierarchy
and there are people who are giving you
orders and that's a part that i think
has been largely neglected in political
dis
what happens to these workers when the
boss fires them because they
they don't like uh who your
sexual partners are right and the
original
uh what we think of as the free
marketeers adam smith and maybe even
thomas payne is a name that comes up uh
when i read your stuff
um so the free market they
conceptualized as free
for these individual contractors and
also they were happy with something like
a social safety net
right like they didn't mind it if uh you
had the equivalent of welfare or social
security like that was not something
they were against
which might be uh different than how we
think about it in our current discourse
oh yeah so tom paine was the first
person to envision how poverty be
abolished
with a universal social insurance system
and he actually costed out a universal
social insurance system
using numbers from uh
the british treasury okay and shout it
was completely feasible to do this
through and fund it through an
inheritance tax
it does sound very current these debates
oh yeah yeah
no pain was a very forward lick looking
thinker and smith too
you know i've read i've read smith's
works
a lot of them most of them i would say i
haven't i haven't plowed through all of
his correspondence
but his major works and he only said one
thing against the poor laws so the
england was the first country in europe
to recognize
care for the poor as a state
responsibility well a responsibility at
least of local governments okay
um uh but all the poor had to be taken
care of
and smith only had one criticism
ever of the poor laws and that was uh
aspect of the poor laws known as the law
of settlement
which meant that if you needed help
welfare support you had to go back to
the hometown of your birth
and he said that's like really stupid
because it inhibits labor mobility
yeah right your if your job
opportunities
somewhere else you might be afraid to
move there
because you wouldn't get any assistance
if something goes bad
right in your life um and he
you know he did favor labor mobility so
people could take advantage of
opportunities all over the country
uh and so he he didn't like the law of
settlement
but otherwise he had nothing at all
against and that actually leads right
into
one of the things you bring up in your
book which is that uh
there's this myth or story around
the modern free market where you know if
the workers being exploited
they can quit and go somewhere else but
in fact this freedom to exit your job
and just get another job
in reality is much less in the modern
world than we might
like to pretend it is yeah so here
here's something that i learned by
looking at labor conditions tipped
restaurant workers
are subjected to extraordinarily high
rates of sexual harassment
they're so high that if you quit one
restaurant and enter another restaurant
you're just as likely to suffer sexual
harassment it's so pervasive
so you know where where is the server to
go
right it's kind of like you're in
eastern europe imagine eastern europe
had its own version of the eu
and you had free migration you know it
behind the iron curtain back in the day
when eastern europe was all communist
okay so you could go from poland to
hungary but it's still communist
you're not going to be more free so
freedom of moment doesn't necessarily
help you that much
and as you point out we cede to our
employers in the modern world an
enormous amount of control
over our lives i mean maybe academics
like you say are a little bit privileged
here but
uh this is why the label private
government makes sense you're
you're analogizing the control that
employers have over their workers lives
to the
control that we think should be the
providence of the government but the
but the firms actually are the ones who
are wielding it
and in fact yes and the thing is is that
bosses employers
have extraordinary powers that even the
government doesn't have
so for instance if in the during the
pandemic you saw a lot of doctors and
nurses complaining
that their hospitals uh were not
supplying adequate
personal protective equipment and some
of them were fired for saying this
yeah you know the government's not
allowed to fire you because you're
complaining
in fact under american labor a lot you
actually
workers are supposed to have rights to
free speech to complain about bad
working
but in practice those laws are not
really enforced and they're very
difficult
well this does bring up the analogous
question to before
you know how are we supposed to change
this i mean if the industrial revolution
flipped on its head the idea of the free
market to go from freedom of the workers
to more freedom of the firms
to uh set prices and things like that
what kind of
system or organization would give
workers back
something closer to that freedom of
movement
and choice and and living their lives
without their bosses telling them what
they can tweet about
yeah so i do think that we could do
several things
one thing is to draw sharper lines
between
workers off-duty lives and their on-duty
lives
so it does make sense that there has to
be
some order giving within the
organization just to make sure that the
work gets done
sure and there and there is some degree
of open-endedness to the tasks which you
can be assigned
so you know if you're say scooping out
ice cream cones
for customers at an ice cream shop and a
little kid
accidentally spills the ice cream cone
on the on the ground
on the floor the boss has to be able to
say
you know mary go clean that up
right and that's fine and i don't think
anybody has a problem with it
unless it's always mary that's getting
picked on and it's inequitable
right you know you want to make sure
there's an equitable sharing of tasks
especially
unpleasant tests um but it doesn't mean
that the boss should be able to
interfere with say mary's off-duty life
like who her sexual partners are or her
recreational activities or her lifestyle
it's really none of the boss's business
how she leads her life off dude
you know if she's not performing on dude
then you can raise some complaints
but off duty really bosses shouldn't
have that power under american law
though
we have a system known as employment at
will which means that
bosses can fire workers for
any or no reason at all with only a few
exceptions carved out
mostly having to do with discrimination
you can't fire somebody
gender and so forth right but
i i think there should be stronger
protections for workers off-duty lives
okay that that actually does make sense
that's a pretty
when you put it that way who could
object maybe other than the bosses i
guess
well the bosses some of the bosses would
object but
part of it is it just means that you
move closer to
um an employment regime where
where the employer would actually have
to show cause right
to fire somebody because you always
wonder is it that they don't like by
you know who i voted for or who i'm you
know which candidate
so you could see why the bosses would be
against that and probably given our
previous conversation
those bosses have a lot more say amongst
the legislators than
the workers do to be sure
and that was something even adam smith
noted in his day
yeah that the legislators are always
listening to what he called the masters
that is the employers
okay very good that brings up the fact
that you know
part of this ideology that we have in
the western world in the united states
and elsewhere
is the idea of the work ethic right the
idea that
it is somehow good and valorous
uh for a human being to want to work
really really hard and
you could clearly see why this might be
something that the boss
class would encourage but i like how you
you dug back into it way back into the
beginning of the reformation i suppose
that's right yes so i dug back into the
original
texts the founding texts of the work
ethic
which was an ethic that was invented by
puritan ministers
in england in the middle of the 17th
century
and what i found was that there's really
two
work ethics that were already there
in the mid 17th century and held by the
same people that is they actually had
kind of contradict views about work
so one view remember these puritans
they're all
uh advocates of a kind of ascetic
morality of self-denial right not too
much indulgence out there because that's
the way of sin
and from that perspective they saw work
as a kind of ascetic discipline
you know if your nose is to the
grindstone then your mind will not
wander off to like
sinful thoughts of lust and so forth
right
and they also thought that if you work
like crazy that would be your best
evidence that you're saved right and if
you slack off that's
a sign that you really don't have faith
in god and so you'll be damned to ever
and that would also make people out of
anxiety
for their for their future in the next
slide they would work really hard
so those tend to those ideas tend to
incline
to a view of work that capitalists can
easily exploit
very little surprise yes all these
anxious workers
right desperate for salvation nose to
the grindstone
but there's another vision of work that
these puritan
ministers had which was that work is
sanctified
because when you work you are performing
god's will
and what is god's will for human that we
all
work promote the welfare of our fellow
human
all of them without exception everyone
counts
and so work becomes sacred and honored
and and they stress that in the most
medial worker
was doing socially necessary be honored
and respected
and treated and paid and afforded safe
working
and treated with dignity and respect
yeah
and the and both of those ideas over
time
get developed into two very different
work ethic
one that rationalizes the subjection of
workers to
relentless labor at very low wages
but another that exalts workers and say
hey you know we're the ones who are
holding up society
right we're the ones who are taking care
of people and doing all the work
we should you know get rewarded for that
it shouldn't just be the lazy landlords
who are collecting the rents
i have to ask because maybe i'm just so
embedded in the american culture or
whatever
but did people not have an ethic to work
before the protestant reformation was
this something that
would have been unheard of i mean i
would think that some people
you know just felt that dignity whether
or not their
theological bettors told them to
you know let me illustrate this
different i do think that the work ethic
represents a major revaluation of values
the valorization of work really was a
new thing in the mid 17th century
because before then people valued
leisure
okay and that is the leisure of the
independently wealthy
so before then the dominating value
system
was that of the landlords the
aristocracy right the best
life is the life where you don't have to
work you want to be the idol rich
that's your goal correct yes
and have other people work for you yeah
okay
and the puritans turned that around and
you know their favorite metaphor was of
a bee's
society you know bees have their own
society
and you have the worker bees who are
doing all the work and making all the
honey
and then you have the queen and then you
have the drones
those drones in the nest those are the
idle landlords because what are they
doing they're not doing any work they're
just having sex with the queen
right and so yeah the parents said these
these
they should be cast out of the nest yeah
got it
very very good it's interesting because
there's this parallel i guess and it's
i'm sure it's intentional uh or at least
it's explicable uh between the two
notions of the free market and the two
notions of the work ethic right i mean
there's sort of a
worker-centered version of each and a
boss-centered version of each
exactly right yes and so payne
tom payne who wanted everybody to be
self-employed
he's part of what i call the pro-worker
working
right this is a way to uplift now they
can have freedom
and equality if everybody gets to work
their own capital and has social
insurance so that if they
some accident and disable theirs will
survive and that goes yeah so that goes
hand in hand
with some kind of social safety net but
then it goes right into modern
arguments about should we give
social benefits to people who aren't
working
yes we just give welfare versus workfare
i suppose like are we removing the
dignity of work
by making it possible to live and
survive
without necessarily doing your job ah
well so i just want to insert a feminist
observation here
please and that is that this obsession
that people on welfare benefits have to
work
is downgrading the value
of women's dependent care labor taking
care of children
and ill people within their household
and in fact if you look at the history
of welfare in the united states
uh before the welfare reform under
president 1990s
and you look at the labor force
participation of very poor women what
you find
is that they were in and out of the
workforce that is the wage labor force
and a lot of that was because they're
taking care of
children or ill and disabled people
within their families
and and so they couldn't devote
full-time
to work because they had dependent care
responsibility
now if you look back at the original
work ethic that the puritan
came up with they recognize that
dependent care work
is socially necessary children need
they need to be cared for and and so you
know this obsession that
that you know poor women have to be
working for wages grossly undervalues
uh the importance of dependent care work
within the family
i mean this this is this is all evidence
for
the point of view that moral and ethical
philosophy should be
not uh focused on finding the perfect
answer but responsive to the moment
because what we're seeing over and over
again here is
you know some kind of values are
promulgated and absorbed and recognized
but then the system changes and the
words that we attach to the values
don't and so the outcomes become very
different i mean
uh i don't know if it's just the
industrial revolution or
things much much later that caused some
of the problems
you're talking about i mean you
mentioned in the 70s we saw this
divergence between wages and
productivity for example so the night
the 1970s not the 1870s or 1770s so
something is still changing now that uh
separates out the work we do from the
what we earn from it right yeah so
in fact there's a remarkable parallel
between
uh the 19th century and uh
recent history from the mid-70s on
so if you look at the beginnings of the
industrial revolution
there was a period in the basically the
first half of the industrial revolution
until
right through the mid 19th century where
gdp per capita was just growing very
very quickly
but wages were stagnant right workers
were working harder than ever but they
weren't getting any of the gains
yeah then around mid-century uh uh you
enter a period
of of wage gains uh
a lot of that propelled by worker
mobilization both for democracy okay
you get a more responsive government
because you have a widened franchise
and also labor organization
there's a lot of agitation of workers
for benefits right
uh and it worked work um right democracy
works
sometimes uh democracy both in the sense
of
electoral democracy but also you know
worker organization
getting out in the streets and so forth
the protesting social movements work
and what we find is starting around the
mid 1970s
a similar divergence took place where
gdp per capita is galloping ahead that
is labor productivity is galloping ahead
but workers wages stagnate okay and and
we're still in that era now
well no wonder a lot of people are
really angry especially working-class
people
yeah yeah now you know contemporary
populism and units i do think has a
misapprehension
of causes right and so a lot of
working-class white people think that
what's getting them down is all those
immigrants
yeah and it's actually not true
but of course you can't necessarily
blame them in the following sense
i mean it actually takes a lot of social
scientific research to find out
social causes you can't just look out
there and see
causes well you know that as a physicist
right yes
right takes a lot of hard data crunching
to figure out what's going on
but uh so i you know i i
i'm not blaming them for not knowing
because they've been told some
bad stories yeah okay about social
causes and what what are the causes of
their distress
but the distress is real i do want to
get on the table
you to be fair you make one point which
i thought was very interesting and sort
of obvious in retrospect that
uh to the boss's credit uh there's not
as many idle rich
around anymore as there were you know
it's not just the workers who are
working really hard but the ceos these
days
tend to work really really hard is this
it's unbelievable
how many hours they put into their labor
so you might have noticed
elon musk when he was called up by some
journalists
who announced to him which he wasn't
tracking that he was now the richest man
in the world at least for a little bit
uh and and he says oh how strange
well back to work
no but i do have to say that while it is
true that the richest people are working
like crazy
in the sense that they're working very
hard to make a lot of money
it doesn't follow from that that they're
working
in the original work ethic puritan sense
where work means actually promoting
the welfare of your fellow human beings
right
so if you look say at um big pharma
pushing all the oxycontin and other
opioids
on americans and turning millions of
americans into addicts yeah they were
really really busy
selling these drugs
this is not productive labor it's very
awful
horrible labor right and so
i think we have to question in many
cases not all cases but in many cases
how this money is and the other thing
that you highlight is uh
david graber's point about the [ __ ]
jobs uh
which let's try to get this exactly
right because a [ __ ] job is not
just a bad job it's not cleaning toilets
or whatever because those obviously have
good impacts we want the toilets to
they're socially necessary
labor that's right right but so the
[ __ ] jobs toilets must be cleaned
[Laughter]
what makes a job bullshitty is that it
doesn't really do any good for society
you might you might not even be a ceo
you know there's plenty of middle
management that is not doing any good
for society either
that is correct and so david graber who
unfortunately died
but but he wrote this fun book called
[ __ ] jobs
in which he defined a [ __ ] job as a
job that is so pointless or
pernicious that even the person doing
the job
can't feel that it's justified although
they have to pretend that it is
[Laughter]
and so i actually taught a course um
uh a couple years ago uh on work
ethical issues and political issues
surrounding work in which we took a look
at
uh david graber's book [ __ ] jobs
and in that book graber estimated that
40
of jobs in rich capitalist economies are
[ __ ] jobs
and so i decided i would just before we
entered into a discussion of the book i
would just take a poll of my students
how many of you have worked at a
[ __ ] job and believe it or not 40
of them raise their hands it must be
true
and so i wanted examples like what made
it a [ __ ] job
yeah and here's my favorite example of a
[ __ ] job
a student was working at this firm
and he had to write reports about you
know the performance of the firm or
whatever
that he had to upload to uh
you know a site that was accessible to
all the other workers in the firm
uh and the site let you see
how often the report was downloaded and
his report got zero downloads
and he realized that his job was to
write reports that nobody read
yeah okay that's right that's a [ __ ]
job
can't argue with that one yeah
and it's an important thing because
exactly because of this idea
that the work ethic was originally tied
into
or at least on in some in some uh
formulations of it
the idea that you were doing work for
some good purpose for something
meaningful it wasn't just to earn a wage
it's not just that
i work hard and i provide it's i work
hard and i provide to society as well
right
correct and you know i mean what is a
meaning fundamentally it has to be
something that's helping other people
and not just oh
yeah yeah and so
uh is this why is it like this is
it is it uh an inevitable thing that
happens when society becomes big and
complicated and bloated and bureaucratic
or
is it a matter of ideology where we just
talked ourselves
into it uh should we have seen this
coming
you know i think we've talked ourselves
into a lot of things
and in a way i do see this as a
manifestation of
this negative work ethic that treats
workers very harshly
and this internalized sense that so many
americans have that well i got to be
work
all the time like a lot
and it's a very american attitude you
know if you go to europe
yeah first of all one thing that's very
strange and i think americans don't
appreciate
is that we're the only rich country in
the world
that does not by law guarantee paid
vacations to everybody
you go to denmark and everybody gets
five weeks
of paid vacation and then a whole bunch
of paid holidays on top of that
yeah it's almost unimaginable
right yeah it's difficult and in france
you know practically everyone takes all
of
august off and they're paid
whereas in america um only about half of
workers
get paid vacation through the employment
contract
right and the other half don't get any
paid and even if you look at those who
are entitled to paid vacation most
american workers do not take
all of the vacations they're entitled
even the ones doing [ __ ] jobs yeah
even doing [ __ ] jobs yes
[Laughter]
so i do think americans could could work
less
it would be good for us good and so that
is a
that is maybe not so much a structural
thing as a
an ideological thing like we we've sort
of let ourselves be talked into the fact
that there is virtue in working hard and
not vacationing
whatever it is the job might be well but
i also think that there's a lot of fear
of getting fired if we're not
yeah okay right being visibly in front
of our bosses
so how do we make the world a better
place i mean i know that
uh there's been increasing talk about
universal basic income
things like that and i know that there's
been pushback against that
both on practical grounds but also on
surprisingly moral grounds right or
ethical grounds the idea that it would
remove the dignity of work that it you
know if if you're not working
if you're just enjoying your life you're
less fulfilled as a person
is that something we can talk ourselves
out of maybe well i don't
look i do think it's very meaningful
to contribute to the welfare of others
and wage labor is one place but not the
only place
to be doing that uh you know there's
also dependent care
labor within the family but often if you
want to make a bigger impact
it's helpful to be part of an
organization that extends
right it has impacts beyond the family
and there could be something that's very
fulfilling about that and very
meaningful so i'm all in favor of
non-bullshit jobs like jobs that
actually help people
yeah and i think the vast majority of
people do find
that meaningful so i don't think we're
going to be at a loss
for motivation to work even if people
also at the same time
get a lot of free stuff right but i
don't necessarily think that the the
universal basic income is the best way
to package
uh benefits i think that requires a lot
a deep dive in looking into the details
of different ways of packaging
so when you say that it's not that
you're necessarily against it it's just
that you know this is a complicated
empirical social question and we don't
know the answer yet
the devil's in the details there's so
many different ways to package a
universe
universal basic income sure okay we
really have to see the
proposals spelled out in detail and then
compare it to other proposals
but you do make the point that maybe the
state that the world is in
is one where we're not ready to aim for
a leisure society just yet because
you didn't put it in these words so let
me put words in your mouth and you can
correct me
there's too much work to be done like
saving the planet
yeah i do think that that's right i i
don't think we're quite ready for it
look i mean we're facing
global climate change at you know at
catastrophic
you know levels we have to roll up our
sleeves to get to work on that problem
uh right there's plenty of work to be
done
that means socially necessary socially
urgent work that we have to be
yeah i mean there's plenty of places in
the world that don't have good
infrastructure in health care and things
like that i mean there's more than
enough
well look even american infrastructure
is fine it's not good
adequate investment it's not good i mean
is it
i mean i'm probably just gonna i've
already asked this and it's gonna be
repeating myself
but uh it's from a different angle since
you just brought up the fact that
infrastructure is failing i mean
is it that we're entering as society the
bread and circuses
stages of our advanced democracy are we
have we just sort of lost our edge a
little bit and
uh you know i really do worry yeah that
we're past
peak america right but we're not willing
to do the work
to make this i do find it worrisome yeah
yeah yeah
yeah uh any advice for making the world
a better place i mean what what is your
uh
practical uh i know your philosopher
that's okay but you're much more
practical than most of the philosophers
i talked to
just had a discussion about the
philosophy of math it was very very
different than this one
um what should we be doing to make the
world a better place for
work and dignity and equality and things
like that i think we have to work
at um improving democracy
and that requires uh
communication with our fellows i think
we don't
i i think the quality of public distance
of political dis
is really really bad there's a lot of
insults
trolling mass shaming it's very
unhealthy and toxic
there are better ways that we have to
communicate with each other
and it's only that that will enable us
to pull together
cooperate and solve the problems that
climate change
the biggest one and if i put on my free
market to your hat a little bit
uh for the moment what i would respond
is but you know what is the incentive
structure
that would lead to better communication
and better political outcomes i mean
right now we have a system where
you get a lot of clicks and you get a
lot of views from
saying outrageous things right i mean
that sounds like a
hard thing to change structurally well
you know
i think the social media companies bear
a lot of responsibility for this
there was a study that was reported on
the new york times about
how people are you know on social media
like facebook and they're getting almost
no clicks because they're just posting
on innocuous
and then they happen to post on you know
q anon or some crazy thing and they
don't even necessarily believe but
suddenly they have thousands of
followers and that's very seductive
so they post more and more extreme views
and pretty soon they're talking about
lizard people
right and then suddenly they have like
you know
hundreds of thousands of followers and
they're making a lot of money
i think this is a very perverse
incentive structure and similarly for
people who go around
trolling and insulting and be people
i i do think social media companies are
not
behaving well and the algorithms appear
to be
structured to reward uh the worst
possible
behavior so this might be a case where
the case could be made for raining in
the free market a little bit because we
need companies
again i'm putting words in your mouth
correct me if i'm wrong uh
companies like facebook google apple or
whatever have so much power and
influence
and they got it so quickly in sort of an
almost unanticipated way
that we need to sort of uh there's at
least an argument to be made
for giving them incentives other than
just maximizing the number of clicks
right to make them more responsible
social actors
yeah and so here's where we can come
back to the issue of empowering workers
within the workplace
so just getting back to that what we do
find is a lot of these companies have
very socially conscious
engineers software engineers like they
don't often they don't
really like what their bosses are doing
yeah and there's been a lot of pushback
within the tech companies
uh on this and i do think
that um introducing co-determination
at the big corporations that is where
workers have a say in management
could be one way to make these companies
more socially responsible
and this gets back also to the issue of
meaningful work
yes there are some people who all they
want to do make tons of money and they
don't care how self-socially destructive
they are
but most people aren't so keen on that
you know
they are they they have an ethical core
they want to be meaningful work and not
just work that makes a ton of money
even though it's spreading social
toxicity so most people
right if you empower them within the
firm
they can move it in better direction so
i do think in this case
worker empowerment will probably be one
way to solve the problem because i don't
necessarily think
that the government that is the state i
i don't want them
necessarily to be imposing regulations
that has dangers of its own there are
problems there that's right yes
but there are other ways to empower
other forces um
to to create better tech comp
that is good that's a i like i'd like if
possible to end each podcast on an
optimistic message and i think we
finally
we finally got there there's a lot a lot
of pessimistic messages we had to get
through to
to get there but elizabeth anderson
thanks so much for being on the
mindscape podcast
it's a pleasure thanks for inviting me
[Music]
you